[Music]
[Applause]
booger mcfarland joins us on loan from
the mothership nfl and college football
analysts won two super bowls and uh you
can see him throughout the day and night
on sportscenter and the uh the specialty
shows that they have booger thanks for
joining us how you feeling today
doing good dp man how you doing buddy
doing okay doing okay um
i was curious when you know when you
watch these games do you watch from a
defensive lineman's perspective since
that's the position you played
you know usually i start there and what
they do is very noticeable especially
when you have a premier player there
like an aaron donald or fletcher cox or
in dominican somebody like that that'll
catch my eye initially but if you're
going to really follow the game and
learn the game and study the game you
kind of have to morph out and
look at the other parts of the play
tom brady said that it's rare when he
gets a roughing the passer call
and it feels like tom is maybe
officiated different than other
quarterbacks did you ever feel that way
that you could do certain things with
one quarterback but you couldn't get
away with that with somebody else
yeah that's life i mean it's just kind
of that's kind of hot dp that's how it
goes in life man like we all aren't
afforded afforded the same luxuries
based on who we are and our
relationships and who we know and you
know if our name is a little bit bigger
and a little bit more stature then we
can get away with other things
uh football is just the microcosm of
life like that's no different than what
we deal with every day so yeah uh you
know
treated differently
yeah well listen
and he should be
like if you really just look at it he's
earned the right to get the benefit of
the doubt like when you've played this
game for a long time and you got pellets
on the wall you've earned the right to
get the benefit of the doubt and so he
is and i have really no problem with it
yeah but i always wondered about this
that
michael jordan would get all the calls
well michael jordan didn't need all the
calls but for some reason the best
players get the calls it's the guys who
are the marginal players that need a
call not not the star power guy i know
we want to see the stars be stars but i
talked to a former player in the nba and
he said if mike
michael jordan went down the lane
somebody was going to get whistled for a
foul
whether you fouled him or not and he
said there would be time when i you know
i was called for a foul didn't even
touch michael jordan he said but he was
michael that doesn't seem fair
it doesn't seem fair but i think the
reason it happens is this is that we're
used to those great players doing great
things and if and when they do not do
great things then something must happen
like like these officials are only human
also and so if i'm sitting back there
and tom brady just sailed the ball five
yards over somebody's head and i just
happen to glance up and i look back down
and brady's on the ground and he's he
gives me the hands up sign like hey did
you see that i'm probably going to give
him the benefit of the doubt more cases
than not
let's look back on the teams that lost
this last weekend
i asked this yesterday the team that
lost in the playoffs
that has the best chance of advancing
further next year the patriots won our
poll question i want to know if you
agree with that that they have the
better chance of all these teams of
going further next year
well if if you're saying the patriots
then obviously you believe in mac jones
which i do i think he was really the
steal of the draft to get a franchise
quarterback with that much upside i
think he was drafted at 15. you must
really believe in him number one two you
must think that they're gonna get a lot
more athletic and a lot faster on
defense because if you saw the
difference between the bills and the
patriots the speed factor was it was a
glaring difference
i don't know if they're gonna do that so
i'm not gonna say the patriots i would
probably say the cowboys and everybody's
gonna say well are they changing coaches
are they changing this are they changing
that
they're they're probably not based on
the reports that have come out but
they're just so talented and it's one of
the reasons why they're the most
disappointing team this season would you
change yourself
no i wouldn't because at some point you
have to have continuity uh to continue
to climb the mountain changing coaches
is not going to do anything but but
solve the moment it doesn't solve the
problem of the discipline of the players
and so yeah we can change coaches and as
fans and broadcasters and people who
have shows it gives us good fodder but
at the end of the day does that make
your team better the problem with the
cowboys is not the coach the problem is
the coach i don't think is empowered to
the level that a coach needs to be
because of the owner of the gm the
family that owns the cowboys so you run
into that situation where you can change
the coach and you can bring in this
tough disciplinarian jimmy johnson and
and and
that of the likes but we saw how it
ended with jimmy johnson because jimmy
johnson the disciplinarian the guy who
runs the show
ultimately got a little bit more shine
than the owner and we all know he didn't
like that
if jim if jerry jones had hired a gm a
true gm
20 years ago
finish that sentence
then the cowboys would probably have
two to three more rings
and jerry jones would not be as popular
as he is now but i do think the the
value of the cowboys franchise would be
at the very minimum where it's at now so
this doesn't necessarily come down to a
how do i make my business better like i
always look at nfl teams like businesses
like chick-fil-a or bank of america or
some corporate company how do we make it
better this isn't about that because the
cowboys are the primitive franchise when
it comes to value and worth and and how
we look at them this is about one thing
then
this is about control hey
this is my team i'm gonna run it my way
and do what it do what with it how i
please and when you're a billionaire i'm
assuming i wouldn't know that maybe you
can tell me uh you get to do what what
it is that you like to do with your
billion dollars and jerry's doing that
so dan considering the fact that there
are two of us on this call and one of us
is a billionaire you tell me how do
billionaires treat their money
um
they just
i just keep all of it to myself
very very cautious in in what i do but
you know but jerry's ego like he wants
the cr like getting the credit is so
important for him
and and as a result he doesn't see what
the bottom line could be and that is
we could be winning championships and
and i know that they've done well in the
draft michael parsons fell to them i
don't know if they wanted him i thought
that he was the impactful player in the
draft they didn't want dak prescott they
wanted connor cook
they wanted jerry wanted johnny manziel
like there are these moments
where they have benefited it's but it's
not by design
you're right they've benefited and you
know jerry ultimately i i think steven
has been good for jerry because i think
stephen has given him a little bit of
balance you know we all know who jerry
liked and thankfully steven's there to
say hey i know you like this guy quite
frankly you like everybody but we can't
draft them all how's this going to make
our team better so i give stephen a lot
of credit i give will mcclay i give him
a lot of credit also a guy in that
personal department who helps but jerry
is
jerry has to be reigned in
and told no i'm sure jeff bezos has to
be reined in and told no at some point
like when you reach a certain level of
of of monetary value and economic status
you have to have people in your life
that are willing to say no not just yes
man and i think over the course of years
jerry is stephen has been developed or
he's developed to be that
i just think jerry ultimately has the
final say so and and until he
relinquishes that
that part of the general manager had
then i think the cowboys are going to be
in a position because you know as well
as i know a team that's the most
penalized team in the league that is a
reflection of the coach well you that
means you need a tougher coach that
means you need a coach that's going to
emphasize because you are
what you emphasize no different in life
and so mike mccarthy has to change
personality wise but guess what he's the
exact personality that jerry wants
because he can
and i i'm not saying that he's telling
tell him uh jerry's telling mike what to
do and what to what to say at practice
but ultimately jerry knows that mike can
kind of beat the drum that he says be
too
talking to booger mcfarlane espn nfl
analyst um
the most dangerous quarterback left in
the playoffs is
josh out
and he's got to be
um because this team is so quarterback
centric
they can't do anything offensively
without the quarterback you say well
booger isn't that every team uh i
present you to tennessee titans because
if derek henry shows up and they and
they run the football the way they can
run it they really don't need ryan tan
here to do anything except hey remember
we're wearing blue jerseys and every now
and then throw it to the guy wearing the
blue jerseys let's take for instance the
la rams when they run the football the
way they ran it the other night band
against arizona matthew stafford was a
secondary part of the game plan so josh
allen has to be the focus because he's
going to run it 10 to 15 times this
weekend and he's probably going to throw
it another 40 to 50 times
and then that might not be enough
because the guy he's going against is
arguably the most talented guy we've
ever seen at the position in patrick
mahomes so yeah josh allen is that dude
you think mahomes is more talented than
aaron rodgers
um
yes i do just because like aaron is
gifted and we've seen aaron do it for a
long time but mahomes is doing things
maybe he's got a
he's got a a flare for the dramatic a
little bit with the no-look passes and
some of this stuff like he's a showman
and i i think that that in in large part
would give a lot of people
the same
uh thought process when it comes to that
like i would put my home just a little
bit uh above aaron especially now now
aaron at his peak and they're probably
they're probably wasn't what but right
now yeah i think mahomes is the most
talented guy in the sport right now
josh allen 29 passing touchdowns under
pressure since 2020 first among all
quarterbacks
yeah
you know why
why
because
he's 6'5 245 and he knows even when
pressure is coming doesn't affect him
because remember remember dan and this
goes great because we just got through
celebrating big ben and what he was and
first battle hall of famer he's a modern
day big ben that's at that's as athletic
as
um some of these running quarterbacks
like i guarantee you josh allen is
probably a four six four seven guy like
he can run
and so imagine big ben as tough as he
was to tackle in the pocket but now when
he breaks the pocket he can run four
five four six and get first down that's
what josh allen is so it doesn't
surprise me because he's not afraid of
pressure he's not afraid of being hit
he's not afraid of being tackled most
quarterbacks who are afraid of being hit
wilt under pressure that's why you
always say blitz the quarterback look at
matthew stafford matthew stafford
shrivels under pressure we saw kyla
murray calamari monday night he
shriveled under pressure tom brady if
you blow on him he'll fall down like it
doesn't those guys those guys don't want
to get hit josh allen doesn't care
you never got brady did you
uh no i never segregated i pressed him a
few times i knocked him upside the head
he felt me he probably complained to
water anderson or somebody or ad hockey
about me but no i never got it
uh in your last five career games you
had four sacks including one in the
super bowl on rex grossman
that was the only sack by a colts player
in the super that doesn't really count
if you sacked rex grossman come on what
do you mean it doesn't count it's on
this on the statistics sheet are you
going to say
okay
if if if you're going to take that sack
away then you better sure as hell better
take michael strahan's sack of brett
farverway
should tj watt be the all-time single
season leader
i don't know you tell me since you're
taking sacks away this morning
evidently me friday's not coming soon
enough for you
look if you were in studio i wouldn't be
saying this
i'm sure you won't uh no tj watch should
be the all-time sack leader regardless
of how michael strange got it you got to
give him credit for it and we can think
of it what we may which i think a lot of
us think it was given to him he still
got it and there's nothing wrong with
that so tj watt had several
opportunities and i'm sure if you go
back we used to do this thing called uh
at the end of every year our d-line
coach used to make a real and he called
it close with no cigar which is every
sack that we should have had could have
had but we didn't get and i guarantee
you when tjy goes back and looks at his
clothes but no cigar reel he's going to
see another 10 sacks
booker great to talk to you as always
have fun this weekend with the games and
thanks for joining us
dp anytime always and i see al michaels
over your right shoulder with a nice
little signed picture at some point my
goal is i'm going to send you a picture
and hopefully i i achieve a level of
status where you can put my picture um
in the studio at some point
you're you're
you know what i'm looking at the video
rex grossman's falling down you're not
even really sacking him i mean you just
kind of fell on him booger come on
damn man i'm i'm going to preserve our
friendship by saying goodbye tonight all
right thank you booker and send me that
autographed picture that's uh the
greater mcfarland we'll come back phone
calls coming up next here dan
he's going to beat one of us up yeah i
know
he's not going to hurt you well he's got
to go through you guys to get to me
that'll be no problem i know